pour des millions de petits occidentaux
le football est une fête ici dans cette
petite ville du pakistan
c'est un gagne-pain contrefaçon ou
ballon officiel on ne sait pas encore ce
qui est sûr c'est que ces produits se
vendent aujourd'hui autour des stades
britanniques du championnat d'europe
le travail des enfants est un véritable
fléau avec une estimation de 40 4
millions de gamins esclaves l'asie
arrive en tête suivie de l'afrique 26
millions et enfin de l'amérique latine 5
millions l'image d'un autre temps et
pourtant bien actuelle quand il ne
participe pas à des tâches le plus
souvent pénibles et dangereuse les
enfants tombent dans un autre enfer
celui à la prostitution
mais l'europe n'est pas épargnée à deux
heures d'avion de paris comme ici au
portugal
ces enfants dès le plus jeune âge
s'exécute sous la pression de la
pauvreté dans la plupart des cas les
adultes pour des raisons de pauvreté
pour des raisons de dette sont obligés
de faire des emprunts souvent à des
patrons acquis après ils vont remettre
leurs propres enfants pour récupérer
cette dette
elle va se transmettre de père en fils
de père en fille et c'est ça qui est
absolument à combattre difficile
d'enrayer le phénomène les contraintes
de l'économie de marché sont toutes
puissantes
on recherche les coûts de main d'oeuvre
les plus bas le travail des enfants fait
perdre des emplois à la fois dans les
pays occidentaux mais aussi dans les
pays du tiers-monde
dès mercredi les ministres du travail de
173 pays vont tenter de trouver des
remèdes pour que des millions d'emprunt
ne soit plus hors jeu